kizinkiko joseph and his family have
been in this camp for displaced people
in bunia in ituri province since may
their village is at the buddha with
benny territory in neighboring north
kivu it's where one of the most feared
armed groups called allied democratic
forces or adf has been attacking
villages
adf have been fighting with government
forces the troops retreated then the
rebels started attacking us so we also
fled
the government declared a state of
emergency in may effectively placing
ituri and north kivu under military role
to counter the rebels but it has been a
struggle
since we've been here a convoy of
civilian vehicles as quoted by the army
was ambushed by adf several people were
killed and others are missing dozens of
vehicles were burned and the military
escorts have now been suspended a
village was also attacked and about 30
people killed
this camp was set up two years ago but
it is increasingly receiving more and
more people from areas that were not
previously caught up in the conflict it
is one of many idp camps carted across
this province hosting thousands of idps
who continue to flee from this conflict
the new presence of adf in some parts of
ituri further complicates an
ethnic-fueled conflict that's gone on
for decades mainly between lando farmers
and hammer harders more than 1 000
people mostly hammers have been killed
since 2017 and close to 2 million people
displaced the total needs for the drc
were estimated at 1.98
billion dollars which is nearly 2
billion
to aid
16 million people as the most vulnerable
the most vulnerable areas of the country
are ituri north kivu south kivu and the
north of northern tanganyika these areas
where there's so much displacement
require special attention
and unfortunately
at the moment this year we are only 30
percent funded of our humanitarian
response plan
government forces are pushing rebels out
of some areas and people are beginning
to return in this village of nyakunde
those who've come back are receiving
essential supplies to restart their
lives
melchion zanamusi and his wife chantal
say they fled during fighting between
troops and a militia group
we did not find anything in our homes
when we returned
we were starting our lives over
everything was looted
military victories like this one in
yakune are boosting the morale of
soldiers as well as the confidence of
those they are here to protect but some
here say the successes are too few and
quite far apart
catherine soy al-jazeera ituri province